directly to my right is the co-host of
UFC tonight on Fox Sports 1 and along
with Karen Bryant was doing if I guess
the studio coverage of the Mayweather
McGregor quartet around the world in
four days a tour good to see you Kenny
Florian how are you thanks for having me
man
so what do we make of what we saw in the
four days between those two gentlemen if
you will going at it against each other
well you know things got a little crazy
obviously but you know this is why this
fight got put together it's kind of a
fun fight that's kind of a
once-in-a-lifetime thing did is that and
you kind of have to see it like that you
know you get the two guys you know the
best representing their respective sport
course Conor going over in the Floyds
world but you know it's remarkable you
know when I look back on my career and I
go cheese you know when I was fighting I
was making just a few thousand dollars
of fight and here we are
Conor McGregor is going to fight the
best boxer of our generation for over a
hundred million dollars and when you
look at on in those terms and you see
where mixed martial arts of the UFC was
and where they are now and the fact that
Floyd came out of retirement for one guy
who wasn't even a boxer it's it's insane
what Conor McGregor has been able to
come well there is no questioning the
popularity of of UFC and MMA there is of
that there is no doubt you see it and
how much it gets talked about we see it
whenever we have a guest like you on the
show in terms of how how many times a
video is viewed or retweeted etcetera so
do you think that that McGregor can
create a cottage industry of MMA
fighters taking on actual traditional
boxers if he somehow gets past Floyd
Mayweather on can he be the George
Washington right you know even if you
goes out and knocks him out I still
don't think there's there's a strong
possibility that we're going to see more
of these fights I think Conor McGregor
is kind of like the UFC's unicorn
and maybe sports unicorn where he's the
only guy he could really make something
like this happen it's my opinion I think
at he's an amazing amazing mixed martial
arts fighter obviously this is first
foray in a professional boxing but the
reason this fight got put together is
because of his popularity because of his
ability to hype a fight and there's just
very few people who can do that like
Conor McGregor well I'm and I'm with
Kenny flooring of fs1 joining me here
but his popularity took another level
when he told UFC to stick it right when
he said thanks for the cheese right and
I'm out right yes I mean it just we went
up a different level when that happened
yeah so he did that now he's going to
fight in a square ring how does he go
back to UFC win or lose come December
December right he's not worried was
expecting from to have his next that's
what he's saying as of right now um yeah
you know I listen I think a lot of
people are saying you know he's going to
make this 100 million dollar payday
there's no way he goes back to the UFC
but I think that he's trying this
because he knows he's going to make a
lot of money I actually think he
believes he's going to win this fight
that that's just the way Conor operates
I really do however I think he's I think
he still has more to prove in mixed
martial arts I think there's still a
couple fights huge fights out there for
him where he can make you know he's been
making you know I thought was saying
he's making three million dollars fight
he's making it you know over ten million
dollars of fight for four in the URJ oh
right yeah in the UFC and I think that
people don't really get that that's work
that's the level of work honors that no
one else is making that but Connor it
can others get to that point
do you think I think this is what's cool
about Conor McGregor is that you realize
oh wow it is possible it is possible to
make that money and I think that after
this fight against Floyd it'd be hard
for him to turn down a mixed martial
arts fight something he does best and
say no I don't need 15 million dollars
I'm good see now this is what I love
this is what I love about Conor McGregor
okay he makes me laugh from time to time
and he seems like he's straight out of a
Guy Ritchie movie right but his story is
really what because certainly what I do
for a living with the NFL network is is
rip the helmet off of guys and tell
their stories in a way that you don't
know that you just see a guy who is
scream
in yelling during the third quarter
became you don't know what his journey
was and how long he's worked there and
what he does off the field with his
family or community I love those stories
I get into it sure
so that's Conor McGregor story basically
going from back of a car to somebody who
cracked the code at the UFC to start
making as you say eight figures for
fight per might now has got nine figures
that's a story I love I don't like the
guy who is saying stuff like this into a
live microphone this stupid crap with
him and Floyd Mayweather going back and
forth is anybody from the UFC or
Showtime been wringing their hands over
what we just what were what we saw over
those four days I mean yeah it got crazy
you know Conor McGregor lying around
four years ago was you know collecting
food stamps in Ireland legitimately and
now you see where the level he's at and
you know kind of playing the same tune
that Floyd Mayweather played for a long
time just kind of turning it up to 211
but well I will want well I think I
think he realized that that was
something that people attach themselves
to whether they hated it or they loved
it
Conor has just taken it to another level
you know and I think a lot of people
want to see him get knocked out I want
to see him lose this is a weird thing
though because both Floyd and Connor are
kind of playing the bad guy which is a
little strange but I don't know I mean
whatever it is it's working for me dope
people want to see this guy fight and
he's just nobody I don't know nobody's
concerned that they turned anybody off
over those four days I mean I understand
it's a nasty sport or it's a it's a
vicious sport that when but that's when
the gloves touch right right and I
understand that did did nobody in
between New York and Los Angeles in
Toronto and Toronto and New York and
certainly going across the Atlantic say
hey guys what are you doing like what's
like what let's tone it down right like
no I say that I think there's like an
energy going on worldwide where things
are going I mean look at the political
discussion that's happening right now it
where it's gone or it's just complete
chaos and I think it's just spreading
over it over into everything else and
whatever it is it's it's resonating with
people good or bad it's getting
reaction and I think Connor has realized
that he's kind of taking it up a level
and yeah it was ugly at times there's no
doubt about it you know what was said
between Floyd and Connor but you know
these guys these guys are fighters at
the end of the day these are two guys
are going in there do damage on each
other so you can't expect them to you
know be so civil I guess so is it I said
why is that your way of telling me to
toughen up snowflake no it's time I mean
maybe slow slow a little bit Kenny
Florian of fs1 again UFC tonight on Fox
Sports 1 joining me here on the show
let's talk about what's going to happen
hmm
what do you think I'm een the the one
thing that I just can't get past is when
you just look at the length of
McGregor's lights in his career 2/3 of
them lasted fewer than the number of
minutes one single round of boxing right
is how can he against Mayweather survive
yeah and I would say like over 66% of
those fights he actually said exactly
what he was going to do he said I'm
going to knock you out in this round
with this punch in this way
that's why they call him mystic Mac now
against Floyd again I still think that
Conor McGregor believes he's going to
win and this this press tour was really
important for me to see what kind of
mental warfare was going to go on
between these two can't Conor get inside
the head of Floyd Mayweather like he has
for a lot of other great champions in
the US see to the point where they get
overly emotional and do something stupid
in a fight I was waiting for that moment
to see if Floyd was really rattled I
didn't see it if I'm being honest I just
didn't see it I think there were little
moments back and forth between those two
where they were able to rattle each
other but not enough where he's going to
get Floyd off of his game and if that's
the case then it's Floyd's world Floyd's
going to do what he's done so many times
before
despite being 40 years old he still has
speed powers never been his thing he's
never you know he won't get into the
pocket and start trading with you that's
just not his style he's a master of
defense but he's a guy who can do it all
he can fight going backwards he can
fight going forwards he'll hichy and
title hit you from far away he will do
whatever
takes to get the win and I think if
Connor is able to get a couple rounds
deal a couple rounds from Floyd
Mayweather and go the distance
I think that's an achievement and of
itself so for Mayweather for McGregor to
win this
he needs knock him out that that's the
only way I don't catch him with that one
punch there's no way he goes the
distance and gets the win he and he
realized that he's already saying he's
gonna knock them out within four rounds
and I think that's the best approach
he's got to go Berserker mode away
society like that what do you make of
the news that former welterweight champ
Jesse Vargas said that McGregor has
already been knocked out in sparring
what do you make of that yeah I don't
know I mean it's hard to tell you know
sometimes people will jump on a story
and say something just so they can get
press I don't know if there's any
validity to that or how he would know
that there as far as I know I haven't
heard an explanation of why he knows
that maybe he said you know boxing the
boxing world is a small world
so what I don't know if that's true and
if that is the case you know what a lot
of pro boxers a lot of guys I'm sure
Floyd included in preparation for the
fight has been caught or has been
knocked down or knocked out I still
don't believe it though I still don't
believe I I know you know we heard
stories of Tyson getting knocked out
before a few his fight it happens it
you're prepared for a fight and you're
always in great shape to start a camp
but I still don't believe that story
from Vargas
you know it's interesting it was just
maybe at this point last year or about
18 months ago with the conversations
maybe Ronda Rousey should fight
Mayweather I know seriously I will take
the biggest star that UFC has to offer
and stick that person in the ring in
that person was Ronda Rousey yeah it you
know yeah I mean it that obviously
doesn't make sense but there was talk of
it at one point it was quick it really
it is it's ridiculous so I guess now
that's why I think it's important for
McGregor to show up and perform well
yeah that that that that the UFC would
be able to continue to keep sending
somebody against whoever everybody
thinks the best fighter is in the square
ring right is that something UFC would
be into them or they just like what's
one off or let's see how much money it
makes with Showtime I think they want to
see both things I think this is going to
be a
once one off it's going to be a
once-in-a-lifetime thing that they're
trying and yeah I'm sure they're very
curious is yeah and the other thing is
they're smart a lot of ways because win
or lose a lot of people are going to
look at Conor McGregor and go well this
isn't a sport I'd like to see what he
could do in the Octagon and I'm sure
he's going to bring in a lot of fans for
his next fight or at least bring other
fans into the sports so I think it's a
good thing for the school so who else
who's the person in UFC would be able to
make the takes two to tango
yeah I need someone to see McGregor beat
up beat the crap names and in the
Octagon who were those people that can
make this well you know the big-money
fights that just happened was obviously
his fights against Nate Diaz I think
they would probably complete a trilogy
they fought twice at 170 pounds and I
imagine that Conor would probably put
his belt on the line to fight Nate Diaz
for a third fight and a Georges st.
Pierre recently came back out of
retirement huge name I think that's a
fight that they wanted to put together
before um and I think it's a fight they
would probably try to put together again
that would be potentially you know the
biggest fight in UFC history Georges st.
Pierre and Conor McGregor so if McGregor
could somehow label on and say there's
one aspect of MMA that would be allowed
in this fight against Mayweather which
one would you think you would choose
which one of the thanks martial law
which art right choose well Joe Rogan
made a good point you know you add in
any striking element and Conor wins that
fight you know let's say he throw in
elbows I think that would make a lot
about which one would I sit which one
you think he'd choose if he could only
write once I mean myself or if I was
Conor I would tell Connor to use you
just keys kicks you know kick his legs
kick his head
I don't think Floyd would last very long
what if he just did that it you know I
thought about the ground he knows he
knows well I gonna go to the cards at
this point in time because he sees that
Mayweather is just flat-out not gonna
enjoy right and he just knows he just
not so much walks out just flat out
yellow in the moment shoot a shot what
do you think listen if you look at what
Connor did in the press conference he
obviously doesn't abide by rules I mean
he is no one is safe and you never know
what he's going to do it's it's possible
but I knew I know that they do have
something the contracted
does break the rules does break the
rules of boxing that he would be fined a
tremendous amount of man so they they
already were ahead of that you wouldn't
be able to buy any more of those
pinstripe suits now where do you go
buddy where do you get that
I believe it's david august to actually
is based out here southern california
and they made a custom suit and i think
they're going into business together is
gonna Conor McGregor line now hold on a
minute
Wow custom suit you mean that's not off
the rack yeah I know I was look Hollis
I'm off the wrap yes if you can't drive
soon
um it's truly to get one of those and
again what I would love just love just I
just don't know if I have that khones
the most brothers to just show up on
Thursday Night Football one night one
Thursday night
well now I would have to be week 17 and
but with last year my contract really no
hope upon it's like a walk you don't
know by the way you'll know tuned into
Thursday Night Football late December do
they make it in 54 a challenge good to
see you can't even take three hours
anyone please come back absolutely is
here on the Rich Eisen show Jerome
Bettis also still to come don't you dare
move 844 204 riches the number to dial
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show lap follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show